U.S Democrats have defied expectations
in the country's midterm vote to win a
crucial seat to control the Senate
Democrat Catherine Cortez masto has won
re-election in the Nevada Senate race
the victory gives her party control of
the chamber for the next two years of
Joe Biden's presidency Cortez masto
defeated her Republican Challenger Adam
laxalt whose early lead dwindled after
late counted ballots came in
every single one of us well the wind
breaks the historical trend of the
president's party typically losing seats
in midterm elections let's take a look
now at the numbers these are the seats
that are not up for grabs in this
election and if you add all the newly
decided races you can see the Democrats
leading with 50 seats while the
Republicans hold 49 seats one seat is
still open Georgia holds a runoff ballot
in December but with vice president
Kamala Harris being able to cast
time-breaking votes control of the
Senate is now Out Of Reach for the
Republicans
a victory that defied expectations and
history Catherine Cortez masto's win in
Nevada gives the Democrats the 50 seats
they needed to keep control of the
Senate
President Joe Biden received the news at
a summit in Cambodia and sent this
message to the Senate Majority Leader I
tell you what congratulations to Senator
Schumer he's got a majority again and
we're focusing now on on Georgia you
feel good about where we are and I know
I'm a cockeyed Optimist I understand
that from the beginning but I'm not
surprised by the turnout I'm incredibly
pleased by the turnout and I think it's
a reflection of the quality of our
candidates a bitter defeat for Adam
lexalt the Republican candidate in the
swing state of Nevada he was endorsed by
former U.S president Donald Trump but
the so-called Red Wave the Republicans
hoped for failed to materialize
instead the Democrats had their best
midterm election results in two decades
despite President Biden's approval
rating hovering around 40 percent
historically the party of the sitting
president loses seats in midterms
Democrats are hoping victory in the
runoff vote in Georgia in December will
hand them an outright majority in the
U.S Senate
I'm joined now from Washington D.C by my
colleague sumisa muscanda sosumi this
was among the tightest races in the
country but certainly it's a great
result for the Democrats isn't it
certainly it's a great result for the
Democrats I mean this was very close and
we knew heading into these elections
that this race in particular would come
down to the wire I mean what you need to
know about Nevada is that this was the
senate race that Democrats were most
worried about they saw the Democrat here
Catherine Cortez masto as being one of
the most endangered Senate Democrats in
the country she was down in the polls
ahead of the election to her Republican
opponent Adam laxalt what made a
difference was those mail-in ballots
that have been meticulously counted all
week we know that mail-in ballots tend
to skew in the favor of the Democrats
now I spent some time on the ground with
the most powerful private sector Union
in Nevada that is a culinary workers
union and they really are a Powerhouse
for the Democrats they ran a massive
canvassing campaign going door-to-door
with working-class voters with voters of
color in particular trying to stump for
the Democrats essentially because they
say the Democrats are the ones that best
reflect their policies that might have
made a difference but certainly we'll
have to wait and see who voted how but
yes this is for the Democrats a really
significant victory
now assuming we can see it's still very
late at night in Washington where you
are and this news broke rather late on
Saturday uh so our Democrats reacting
and how are they reacting to this
victory
we've seen some Democrats taking to
Twitter for example hailing this as a
victory for democracy for Reproductive
Rights and as a clear repudiation of
Republicans I mean the Democrats in the
lead-up to this vote worked hard to
paint Republicans as extremists that
would put democracy at front and
remember that heading into these
elections we had expected this
Republican red wave that Republicans
would sweep through the House of
Representatives and possibly the Senate
that did not materialize a President
Biden himself has been one of the
loudest voices saying that voters are
very clear that they trust the Democrats
in their policies and he actually
commented on on this Victory um at The
asean Summit in Cambodia so the
president they're referring to the state
of Georgia remember that there is a
runoff there on December 6 between the
Republican candidate and the Democratic
candidate but this does take pressure
off that state to be the decisive factor
in who will have control of the Senate
um this Victory Nevada also means that
Democrats can have a majority on the
Committees in the Senate so that's
another Boon for them so that's
something that the president is
certainly celebrating
well assuming tell us a bit more about
what democratic control of the senate in
fact means for the president's agenda in
the next two years
well we have to wait first of all to see
who wins the House of Representatives
we're still waiting for some very close
races to be called there but if that
does end up that Republicans gain
control in the House of Representatives
they have a slight Edge there we would
be talking about divided government so
one chamber of Congress would be in
Democrats hands the other in Republicans
and that still does mean some trouble
for President Biden and his agenda so
Republicans have vowed that they would
stymie any spending plans he has for
example uh spending on climate change or
perhaps further pandemic relief in the
future and they also have said that they
want to launch investigations into
President Biden's family into the
administration's withdrawal from
Afghanistan Afghanistan rather also into
immigration policies so things might
still get tricky for the president but
remember if the Republicans do get
control of the House of Representatives
it would be with a very small majority
and that would make it harder for them
as well to pursue all of those things
that they promised so we have to wait
and see how the chips fall still in
Congress
twcimisa muscanda reporting from
Washington D.C Sumi thanks so much
I'm joined Now by journalist Matthew
connorsick he's the chief Europe
correspondent for political magazine so
Matthew the Democrats now hold the
Senate looking at this from a European
perspective what are your thoughts
well thanks for having me I think from a
European perspective one has to Rejoice
because it's becoming clear that the
Biden positions towards Ukraine the
United States support of Ukraine is
likely to continue There will probably
be more scrutiny of the military aid and
other Aid that is going into Ukraine but
it doesn't look like the Republicans
even if they wanted to would be able to
do much to stop it now the house is
still undecided but Republicans are
still favored to win there if they do
what is that likely to mean for
President Biden's foreign policy agenda
well I think it really comes down to
this important question of of Ukraine as
I said and I think what what it would
mean is that there would be more
scrutiny of a lot of the spending that
Biden has pushed in support for Ukraine
and uh for the Republicans uh you know
you really have to remember here that
they are also divided on this question
there are some people who want no
support for Ukraine some people want
less support uh but ultimately I think
you know they they are not going to be
able to uh halt the path that Biden has
has plowed here when it comes to Ukraine
and really really to other issues
because it's also worth remembering that
foreign policy is really in the hands
primarily of the president in the United
States and it's only when he needs money
for something that he has to go to
Congress all right that was political
magazines Matthew Connor Schick thank
you for your insights
thank you